you
ladies and gentlemen I feel that this
award was not made to me as a man but to
my work the life race in agony and sweat
of the human spirit not for glory but
but to make out of the material of the
human spirit something which was not
verified so that this award are going to
mine and show that will not be hard to
find a dedication for the money part of
it
commensurate with purpose and
significance of its origin but I would
like to go to the scenes do the same
with the acclaim to buy makings using
this fine moment as a chemical for which
I might be listened to by the young men
and young women already dedicated to the
same anguish in travail among whom with
the one who may someday stand where I
stood this afternoon our tragedy today
is a general and universal physical
sphere so long sustained by now that we
can even bear it there are no longer
problems of the Spirit there's only one
question when will I be blown up because
of this the young man young woman
writing today has forgotten the problems
of the human heart in conflict with
itself which alone can make good writing
because only that is worth writing about
West's agony and the sweat he must learn
them again we must teach himself that
the basis of all things is to be afraid
and teaching this himself that forgets
forever leaving no room in his workshop
for anything but the old virtues and
truths of the heart the old universal
truths bucking lacking which in his
story is ephemeral and doomed love and
honor and pity and pride and from
passion and sacrifice until he does so
he lives on da case he writes not of law
but of lost of defeats in which nobody
loses anything of value on victories
without hope and worst of all without
pity or compassion his griefs grieve on
no universal baldwin's leaving old
skulls
he writes not of the heart of the plans
until he releases
Rilla Rilla realize these things will
write as though he stood along and watch
the end of man I declined to accept the
end of man it is easy enough to say that
man has been more accepted because he
was still in yours that when the last
things all of doom had climbed and faith
from the last West's Rock had hanging
tireless and last red and dying evening
that even then there will still be one
more sound that of his puny
inexhaustible voice still talking